okay
12380 uh this is uh November 2nd and uh
our speaker is Ted Zucker who's going to
talk to us about the new company he is
putting together called healthy
yeah hi everybody I'm uh the CTO of
Alfie but more importantly I've always
been interested in how people
communicate using Ai and user interface
for those purposes and I've run Labs at
MIT and CMU on considerate systems as I
call them and today I'm going to talk as
much as about considered systems and my
research as I am probably going to be
about Alfie
um you see on the left of this screen
some of the people that are involved
with this company and our goal is to
advance women
um I will pay about you know just a
couple seconds
revolutionary app designed
urgency women
it's about career again deeper
connections and belonging and better
communication
so the better communication is mostly uh
what this Alfie reflect thing that I'm
so excited about is about and we use
Alfie we use AI throughout the system to
recommend things and to help people
improve their understanding of who they
are and what what they um are learning
and what they can do you see here on the
right hand side kind of a uh an image of
a kind of a report card that it gives
you it's not my favorite but it's one of
the things that we uh do within Alfie to
help people understand uh how they are
how they are
pronouncing themselves
um I'm going to start with um this this
talk has these uh five parts uh and I'm
gonna start with AI can help human uh
interaction
so AI uh can help humans communicate
um if you look at what ai's been helping
over the last uh while it has been
successful in various regards although
for a long time people believed it
wasn't going to be reliable
um or predictable at interacting with
people in the 80s it helped with
investment opportunities and made people
very rich people like d e Shaw who is a
PhD student here
um online searches in the 1990s became a
huge uh use of of AI e-commerce in the
2000s and car safety began using it in
many ways everything from from
representation uh and modeling of
people's braking uh in in a ABS to to
other things as well in fact ten percent
of car fatalities come from driver
technology overload uh so
um this is this is you know there's
books written about it and and in fact
my student Raul Rajan at Carnegie Mellon
wrote a paper with me where we actually
were able to use a very we tried 13
different Biometrics and found one that
could discover uh using it's a camera
based one uh whether you're stressed
fast enough that we're able to get
people to stop making
um errors and in fact avoid crashes in
our simulator or driving simulators so
AI can help in that way uh if you notice
the difference between that and uh the
way that the autonomous vehicle
Direction's gone my stuff tends to be
about helping Advance people as opposed
to replacing them uh you know if you you
know give a person a fish stay fish
tonight if you teach a person how to
fish they fish for their life and I
think in in general there's an awful lot
of
um
issues there's a lot of value in
simplifying our life by doing things for
us but there's also some value in
learning
um and here we are at Stanford so
um technology and disruption and
frustrations have been part of many many
meetings
um and uh one of my systems Roger that
that we'll hear a little bit more about
later
um
that if it uh if it if it says Ted
selker has entered the meeting it
actually is a disruption for everybody
so uh we've done some things to think
about uh ways of improving
um how how communication happens to
people when they're interacting and if
you think about a meeting it's actually
human human communication
interaction that the computer now is
starting to mediate so that's kind of
interesting is how we are moving from
human computer interaction to human
human interaction in our nursing in our
goal goals for for a lot of a lot of the
systems we make so I I I stand here to
tell you that automated feedback needs
considerate systems what is a
considerate system well a context aware
system is one that um is aware of what
you're doing and where you're doing it
using sensors and AI modeling
um and AI modeling uh includes so many
things we can use I mean today we use
Transformers we used to use neural Nets
we still do random Forest support Vector
machines hidden Markov off mobs Common
Sense rules rules are still a big deal
knowledge representation has been part
of
um uh you know expert systems and and a
lot of time people say that stuff isn't
cool I was I will I have a lot of
examples where uh simple uh simple
methods of reasoning
um can be can be quite helpful but in
any case my view my my my my position is
that
um systems are only helpful
to people when they respond in socially
appropriate ways we we have been living
in a world where computers are
egocentric and they expect us to
understand everything they understand we
never do that with another person we we
start off by trying to make them feel at
ease that we're actually not going to be
um a pain uh and so
um this this idea of adding this element
of empathy to to the computer is
something that I've been really focused
on for for for decades
um if you look at
social contexts in which online tools
help people did they have a long and an
illustrious uh and and also uh bad uh
background our email uh we're faster
than letters but flaming became a
problem right off the bat at the very
beginning flaming is when you uh are un
filtered and make dramatic statements
um Stanford AI lab a few steps away from
here I built a system there where uh we
used
um a common frame buffer where everybody
could collaborate and it supported that
entire community of researchers working
together with you know keystrokes
intertwino I think that we now do online
is is edit together happened all the
time there but but uh backing off to you
know what what happened with this
communication again bulletin borders uh
without monitors go dramatic just to
give you an example I was in the room
when the CEO of IBM a guy named Lou
grishner was being shown for the first
time a bulletin board and he typed in hi
I'm Lou and what came back was hey Lou
want to screw
and uh he said oh yeah I knew they would
be like that uh which was you know sad
because they aren't only like that but
people want to be noticed they want to
make a presence of themselves and they
go dramatic it isn't just uh the social
media platforms although they have been
accused of bias towards and making
dramatic dramatic silos
um you know and they use all sorts of f
now Facebook spends a lot a lot a lot of
energy trying to to counter this in fact
my I heard through the grapevine uh
maybe it's not true that they have 15
000 people trying to monitor uh Facebook
right now that's pretty crazy of course
they also have ai Bots doing it too but
uh you know and if you go and you say
well where where has the green always
represents in this in this in these uh
this uh places where things went well so
slumberger long ago started representing
everything about a person whether they'd
taken a course whether they'd dug a dug
a dug a uh oil well whether they you
know so you know whatever they've done
at slumberset and they used this in an
automated way to build teams
um to to to uh go off and do some some
Consulting to build a you know to make a
oil well or something and
it was so important to them that they
they wouldn't share the software with
anybody so you know it's people's
experiences helped them it seems quite
not natural right now but when I first
ran into this it was it was a big fancy
thing travel role is a is a uh um a
prototype uh uh shy ride sharing system
that I designed and actually published
about where it kept track of
um
why it would expect that you know I and
you Dennis would be okay in the car
together
you know a little bit around when Uber
was being formed and then what was my
need and your need that was coincidence
so you know I want to I want to study
French three times a week it would
notice right and so I also want to go to
the ball game and I live close to you so
maybe say hey why don't you guys go to
the Ball Game find yourself speaking
some French
um so uh coach was
um a more complicated thing which which
actually is still believe it or not sold
in what used to be os2 and what what is
it is it or does is it watches your
demonstrated performance and experience
and decides how to help you based on
that what helped to give you
um in a hierarchy of
um of of of abilities going from novice
to to expert and uh people using it in
my experiments uh produced five times as
much code as people that didn't use it
including the same exact
um help
it was choosing this is this came you
know this was done my PhD it was done at
a time when people believed that any AI
in the user interface was going to be
brittle and difficult in fact it
competed beautifully uh so how did I do
that well we can talk a little bit more
about that but uh empathy buddy is a
system that uh weighs heavily on this
talk and I probably shouldn't be going
through this in this detail but it it um
it's it's all about making people aware
of how they're how they believed as a as
a as a communicator and uh happy sad
surprised angry emotions that the
psychologists always talk about it kind
of put those up on the screen in
pictorial form and people uh did uh
reflected on the emails they were
sending and actually changed them so
as I go go on uh I will just say that
Roger that is another communication
support system considered conference
calling system is one alpha recommend is
and these these last uh you know five or
six are all things I've built but Alpha
reflect is most pre Uh current one and
it um uh also recommend and Alfie
reflect um it previews how people will
uh how other people might interpret your
contribution and makes you a little bit
aware of that so uh my I I would start
my AI can help interactions Story by
saying that technology is inevitably
used for social purposes everything
people do is about other people
um and and I want to move on to we're
always social actors so
um AI can be considerate the question is
when am I doing something uh
remember talking doing something or
thinking uh timing uh for requests and
response is kind of part of being
considered isn't it uh you don't want to
be talking over another person how
social rules of engagement you know uh
include that you know maybe there should
be five affirmations for one one uh
criticism you know that's something
people talked about anyway what does
listening mean anyway
um what peripheral you know I'm aware
that my my PowerPoint might go down the
door might break the
projector might fall from the ceiling
but that's not what I'm thinking about
I'm thinking about these PowerPoint
slides in front of me and that
peripheral stuff I'm able to keep out of
my mind unfortunately with egocentric
Computing they they tend to as this one
did pop something up that I have to pay
attention to which isn't typically the
way people interact with each other
unless they absolutely are falling down
or something uh why appropriate
responses are fundamental to social
success
so the there we are so so in fact the
first thing I wanted to talk about in
Social actors was that when we were
communicating with a person we use you
know non-verbal behavioral cues like
their posture and their height and their
gaze and their vocal behavior and their
forward posture and their interpersonal
distance and Destroy and
what they're saying so they start with
an intentional stance they have social
actions and then we recognize the
activity with
in this case text and then we have uh
intentionally
recognition and finally we have a
rational agent that does something so
that kind of that kind of circle is is
kind of what happens in a social Dynamic
there's a couple of papers uh that are
really nice about that
um that stuff
um and and in fact when we want to be
considerate
um we want to uh inform uh and and
negotiate a relationship Stephen Pinker
talks about that uh considerate systems
are have this appropriate social uh
feedback and my case I want to say what
using AI models of social context and
user and the point is to reduce uh
effective load you aren't going to be uh
as worried about your emotions control
responses and reactions to each other
because the information is pertinent and
valuable thoughtful and caring receptive
and reciprocal not distracting and
disruptive and condescending and hostile
and manipulative
right so okay so somehow it had jumped
to these two slides before but this is a
huge number of examples that I've made
over the years to demonstrate some of
these ideas and to explore them and
often what I've found in running
experiments is that um what I started
off as a as what as a vision turned out
to be a question so for example with
empathy buddy up at the corner left
um that funny ugly face up there was the
result of it not are people not
responding at all very much when it was
text that said surprised angry happy sad
but the Picture People responded very
quickly so the interface and the
interaction in that interface is always
critical to to um to part of the to
unders to going from the recognition
um and the interpretation to the action
as I was showing in that Circle earlier
um so as an example
um of of uh reactions uh expressing
intention here's Andrea Lockard she's
now a full professor at um uh at
University of uh Texas in Austin and
Floyd Mueller is an uh Professor these
are two of my students um in Australia
um and what they did
is they went out with a couple of uh
sensors on them
um and one was a GSR that's galvanic's
skin response when you're upset you
sweat
um also you sweat when a car honks a
horn or when the cloud goes overhead so
that uh you see uh the galvanic skin
response going up and down and up and
down and up and down while they are
filming there's a video camera and she's
filming people around around
um uh Harvard Square actually uh right
at the right at that uh the red line in
uh entrance to the subway and what we
see is that she giggles
these four times and those gigglings
correspond to somebody videotaping her
videotaping them somebody playing uh
drums on a
um you know on in the street
Etc the point is that those are actual
places where she was delighted by what
she was videotaping and so even though
it seems like a very blunt uh
um piece of information her voice was
quite strong at indicating what she was
interested in what she was doing much
more much better than the biometric that
that people have been playing with at
that at that stage and uh so that that's
that was kind of exciting to me
um in trying to um understand social
mistakes just
um I'll give you an example of this this
uh study up here we had
um somebody that was dominant they were
this this represents that while there
were two people were trying to work out
um a chess a a chess situation where
there were three Three Steps From A
Checkmate and they had to work together
to solve this problem
um this green person was doing all the
communicating until we said
and that statement of turn taking made a
precipitous drop in their dominance and
the person that wasn't speaking at all
down down here
we had them we said to them
and they immediately started
collaborating at the same level as the
person that had been dominant and this
is five minutes notice that yeah the
dominant person gets a little more
dominant but not much what's shocking to
me is how that little intervention
verbal intervention made a huge change
in the in the in the relationship
between these two people
um just to give you an example of
um of of that Ted has entered the room
here here's here's a two alternatives to
Ted has entered the the uh the meeting
John so that is a door opening and
saying John notice that the error rate
is very similar to Ted has joined the
enter the meeting above let's take a
look at an alternative
this is me leaving the meeting John
so we literally by saying John as we
leave the meeting and John as we enter
the meeting we're able to get half the
errors
in Communications between people not not
in people knowing whether he was there
but literally the mistakes people made
in communicating with each other so I've
done a bunch of this and some of it is
in um these papers uh and more of it has
crept into a system I've made called
c3.chat you're welcome to go online and
and try out this video conferencing
system I've more or less uh waiting uh
for for uh
um to have the funding that it needs to
go forward but what it does in the
meantime is it does make people aware of
who's speaking and improves their
ability to communicate
um uh you know gen uh over over
um not having interventions like that
and it uses AI to do that it has this
modeling
um another another example of something
I built that was um
so in this case what you see is a
background is there was a desktop and it
had a window open with a spreadsheet and
a window open with your email a window
open text messaging a window open with
with with an order form and your job was
to sit there for an hour and a half
filling out orders and you'd sometimes
get a text message from somebody
um saying hey we've changed we you know
we're out of inventory or we've changed
the pricing or or by the way you know
you should take a break now so someone
who is social some of us work related
and um anyway this this uh up here this
box is kind of modeling the the the
behavior I mean detection and what we
did is we would literally take text
messages that came in and reorder them
by what whether they were about the same
topic whether they're about the topic
you were you were you're operating with
in your email or text or whatever window
you're in whether they were um uh
um
um uh more important than the one uh in
front of them and we would delay them
zero to two minutes okay
25 percent uh performance Improvement
like like the state and we actually
anyway with it's there's a lot of work
that can be done this area it's a very
exciting area just imagine that if you
don't disrupt people when they're doing
something important if it would matter
to them it would okay and and uh here is
my the empathy buddy that I was talking
about quite proud of the fact that
um in 2019 it got a lasting impact award
20 years after it was uh published but
um this is another thing which is this
weird Ransom note and this Ransom note
email system that we built I say Ransom
note because it got this orange and
different sized fonts All These Bars all
over it and all this stuff
um it
it actually
um when people had
um this feedback about whether this was
somebody important for you to respond to
or this was uh some something that was
urgent or whether this was uh somebody
new people uh even though they looked at
the same number of emails as a normal
email system they responded more
appropriately and what was especially
important from my point of view about
this is our this was this was a you know
a little while ago our machine learning
and our modeling wasn't so good it was a
graduate student working on it whatever
um some of our
some of our machine learning was only 60
to 75 percent correct so that means that
the indicators in these awful colors
wasn't even correct and people still did
that
not only that but you did that you know
maybe an email you'd want to respond to
is green and when you know you shouldn't
would be orange oops we made the
opposite direction we said the things
that are orange are
urgent people still did better with it
and they still liked it better so very
interesting lots of opportunity with
user interface to take AI results even
when they are not perfect and design
fail soft interfaces that improve
people's success okay so
um
I've done
lots of different things with uh
thinking about uh feedback
um
and it's really really I guess I will
just
um
I don't know I guess I just want to
point out that
um
okay I'm gonna there's a couple things
that that well track point you guys
might know is the pointy device in IBM's
notebooks there are lenovos that I
designed and what was interesting about
that is that by matching it has a
cognitive model
of of eye movement and handshake and by
matching the abilities of humans we were
able to get a 30 performance improvement
over anybody's joysticks before so that
was pretty impressive
um but you know when we tried to make it
learn
the most interesting part about it was
that when it was learning to see how
fast you could move your finger the the
hardest thing was not to have it
learning about you and you learn you
learning about it so if it changes and
you change those if they get out of
phase you end up with something that's
that's terrible and one thing that we
found out in the in the uh 1980s was
before the 1980s all phones had what's
called side tone side tone is that when
you're talking it puts some of your
voice in the earpiece so you can hear
that you're talking well for a while
cell phones took that away and people
get stressed when they don't have side
tone I believe people get stressed when
they don't have side tone and other in
other regards too I'm relying on you
looking at me intently saying oh my God
I'm not I'm not completely off base in
my in my way of communicating I'm not
wearing a frog on my head or whatever
but we do find ourselves looking at
ourselves in zoom and staring at our
face why because we want to we want to
know we're we're actually succeeding at
especially with zoom who knows you might
disappear
um at communicating with others
um the other thing I want to say is that
constructive feedback is a very
dangerous thing and and
um I guess I will leave you with
um when we were making a
um a car that was trying to improve your
driving by giving you feedback we had
two two knobs on the on the dashboard
one for affirmations and one for
criticisms and when people uh when we
gave people any criticisms at all they
made more errors driving any criticisms
and it was funny as they didn't
recognize it yes I just was wondering
Ted I you know I don't want to interrupt
too much but I see here for for both
emacs and Gmail text completion
spell correction in some cases yes which
is in many which is in many cases for
the person typing of course yeah that's
right so so what's interesting here is a
guy named George heidorn in graduate
school came up with this whole
legibility Improvement for writing and
he turned it loose on some you know you
know Young Writers not not you you're a
very professional writer a lot of
professional writers hate these these
things but in fact they would have in
the center of a huge industry grammarly
and so on
um and and so you know now we have even
things like Gmail and
um and an emacs that do text completion
um thank you for the invitation right
it's going to add those those words
after it
um I I uh another another system that
that we all watched was something that
would dance on the screen would have
thought you needed help uh I didn't uh
people didn't like clippy yeah exactly
and the thing with Bob
or it could be as it became known later
was in my mind it popped up one of the
worst things for an eye is something
popping up over there because it makes
your eye drag over there it's a
physiological response second thing is
that it would talk about why it wouldn't
talk about how and so it would tell you
what you know this this is used for this
purpose because it didn't know quite how
to do that and the third thing about it
is that it would take your eye away from
your from whatever text that you were
editing which again was a distraction
disruption so I I you know I kind of was
bragging at the time the same time coach
came out in what was called smart guides
unfortunately the uh clippy got lots
more attention because well they sell
they sold you know maybe you know orders
of magnitude more Microsoft uh product
than than we sold uh os2 but when when
what I was another thing that I did with
um coach I talked about a little earlier
which was recognizing your level of
expertise and experience is you see this
this cover and you see through and you
see this this
magline glass that is where coaches
literally
um thinking about graphical syntax on a
graphical user interface and helping you
step by step through it with uh novice
intermediate professional or expert
um script and you can go off the script
and it changes what it thinks you're
going to do whatever it has to say how
you see how barely there
um
maybe I'll make it bigger
um it's going to put very close to where
you're working so
that that was kind of um what what it
what it did and I'm still proud of it
now if you reflect kind of takes takes
uh human human communication uh to
another level uh it uses these faces and
icon iconic symbols
um and short texts to to make you aware
of how maybe somebody else will see you
so if you said something like this is
great it's going to have this smile and
it's going to say positive okay so
that's that's just reacting to your to
your speaking and um so here we are
where so much of this industry has gone
about legibility I'm thinking about tone
sentiment and semantics and we had that
one saying this is great we have this is
a perfect way to think about this we
give a uh
um a deferent that's that's uh you know
we call that deferent it's a it's a
thank you for this
um this is a Hot Topic
um is is a more neutral response so
we're constantly actually on deciding
whether and how to give you feedback and
when we started building the system it
was kind of thinking how do we get
Beyond shame blame and complaint we
started off by saying you know when
somebody would say something like women
are not inspiring it have this this
Grimace it's a terrible thing to say and
so then you know maybe it's too edgy
um very very you know negative women are
not intelligent again uh women are not
are not haters it would be happy that
it's very uh are complicated to
understand through 12 rounds of design
of thinking hard about what would be a
reasonable feedback we came up with well
first we came up with terrible ideas
like we had this uh making women and and
Men equal we thought we'd put them on a
scale now we have their heads on a
platter it's a very bad idea
um and we've come to things that are
much simpler so
um
men are Dumber is of course a sexist
statement so we have this this image of
women and men together being equal and
the word inclusive uh you were too old
for that we really loved the idea of of
the sad part about being a kid is they
don't give you the good tools tell
you're 32 and then you're 53 they take
them away again uh so there's there's a
lot of ageism that goes on in this world
and uh so um we kind of have this young
woman and this old older person
um uh holding hands so
um you know are you too old for this job
chooseability not age because these are
a little commentary and they're pictures
of the of the man the young the young
woman and the old woman holding holding
hands um am I making sense
well you know
um that's kind of a roundabout way maybe
we should be
um maybe we should be uh straighter with
our text and just say is this clear
um so that's that's those are some some
examples of um
of of of how how it responds and you
know you can go um to
alfieco.com and you can uh find out more
about it you can also go to your um to
um
to the play play a store or the Apple
Store and download it for your phone and
play with it there
um and you know what where this Alpha
reflect comes to play is when you are
posting or commenting on some uh piece
of content or
um sending in a text uh to somebody else
in the app
so
um the last thing I'm going to talk
about is how we did this with machine
learning
and ai's trajectory uh used to be
knowledge based engineering
um and we used to talk about knowledge
being power but
um you know it it it did lots of things
in the 80s you know it drove factories
made big complex things work you know
configured uh our our two our three our
our two configured computers
um it did it had linguistic models and
medical models and logistical models an
example is
um there was a system at SRI
um that wooden figure
um where to put things like porta
potties and and you know temps and
things in in a bunch of airplanes that
are going to fly fly them into some
remote area and
um they had a simulation that took four
or five hours on a big supercomputer to
to configure these 22 airplanes I guess
they call it I don't know Battalion or
something and and um no one used it and
people would just Shuffle paper around
on a table as a group to decide where
they're going to put things in the
airplane until some friends of ours um
made this rule system that said hey you
know you put the heavy things under the
under the wings and the and you put the
things that are going to slide around
where you can tie them down and and and
you know if you're gonna if you're gonna
let them come out of the airplane on
parachutes you load them a little
differently than if you're gonna have
them come off on forklifts and and and
guess what in one minute it's a long
time ago uh it would configure this
whole airplane all these airplanes and
then then you would interact with it and
move some things they didn't like where
they were and then it would run another
another iteration and immediately
um most of the people doing that kind of
work converted to using it so the user
interface with the reasoning system made
a system that worked with people and
computers working together using AI
reasoning and representation
the trouble with that approach we ran
into a psych psych was this is a system
that's been going for I don't know 40
years at this point it they have ma a
really great model of the Suez Canal in
the Middle East
um and they have lots and lots of uh
other other things that they've modeled
and the problem is that um it's done by
hand and there's a problem with
consistency and in fact even for small
models there are trade-offs and when
something is true and it gets very
complicated to have something that's
reliable and consistent and girdle's
Theorem says that you can't really do it
all so it it runs out of power it gets
very complex and you know 40 years down
the road Psych is not the dominant AI
system we're using
um so did multi-layers Network save us
absolutely you know before we had
multi-layer neural networks uh people
thought that maybe we couldn't do a good
enough job at learning with neural
networks I actually did my undergraduate
thesis and Master's thesis to show that
I thought it would work but that's a
long time ago so the thing that's
interesting is
what do you do to to decide how do you
just throw a bunch of modeling you know
this this machine learning at a problem
you've got a big data set today that's
what we all have and the fact is John
lamping who worked with Greg Hinton and
a bunch of other people making the AI
systems at Google says you gotta eyeball
it first right you have to have an
intuition you have to understand the
topic area you have to understand
reasoning about it or you will not be
able to design an AI system and people
say oh no no no he does it really well
well most the people that you have work
on image understanding with machine
learning did it at another company first
did it at another University first so
the the we really are at a point where
we don't quite understand but we do know
that representation matters it might not
be encoded explicitly in our machine
language machine learning things but um
anyway that's my little rant about that
but uh in Alpha reflect we've got you
know some things to just sing with it
surprise business so you know we we
started off thinking oh sorry whenever a
person says sorry we start off with a
very simple model sorry it was was an
apology and apologies are are no good so
um sorry to bother you versus sorry for
your loss
so an apology is not as is not what that
is that is empathy so we model it
incorrectly for a while we we got
confused between uh sex and sexist we uh
you'd say woman and all all said with
liquid was sexist uh we thought you know
you'd say black and all of a sudden I
wouldn't think it would it would be
racist not racial so this becomes very
interesting and if you look at this huge
um
array here forgive me for not changing
views I just don't want my system to
blow up again
um what you see here is US thinking
about how so many different ratings of
these sentences that we put together as
our training sets uh there were you know
thousands of them now
um uh related to these different
um different aspects that we're trying
to look at we're looking at racist and
sexist and Aegis and and uh confident
and and happy and sad and anyway there's
a bunch of them and um and you know when
you when you when you do stuff like that
you start with training data you do
supervised learning and then you can you
know you can use
adversarial networks too but um you know
you gotta invalue evaluate the
interpretations and the performance and
rethink the calcification let's say we
have built the AI system for Alfie four
times at least that I that I that I can
name literally changing and upgrading
our technique each time we started with
you know the the one shots and we'll get
into it a little bit more but anyway
after you're reassembling the results
when you have this huge bunch of
classifiers all over the floor then what
do you use you use in the bad old days
we used to use blackboards very proud of
blackboards use them in lots of my AI
systems that is that
there's you know there's these uh these
results and they're all vying for for
which One Believes more that it's the
answer and that that's a really great
way to go except that it's kind of a a
single uh it's making a single decision
um and what we find is very complex
backwards with different different parts
to them and then we end up with Bayesian
Nets where we can where that's where all
of these all of these expert knowledge
experts that come back with with machine
learning results can can fight over
which which state they are in a network
and then what what the result should be
well that's all fine and good but in
fact
um we can we can actually do do other
things
um and I'll talk a little bit about that
so we started off with some direct
matching sorry sorry I bothered you
um you know was we found ourselves
saying looking for the word sorry very
not you know it worked for a great demo
um and then we tried to use other
people's uh models hug and face Spacey
and so on
um but they are they're trained for
different reasons and different kinds of
porpoises and different re you know
points of view about what hate means and
what all various things that they've
trained for me
um and so we found ourselves stumbling a
little bit and then we tried to say okay
we can use these beautiful little little
pithy uh training data sets with one
shot learning and it's hard to get
Nuance what we found is
multi-label learning is a much deeper
way of looking at the relationships
between the training sets as well as as
uh reducing the performance problems
that you get by using by Outsourcing to
other people's systems so we found
ourselves owning much more and more and
more of the of the um
of the um of the of the machine learning
until now it's all all done in-house
um and
yeah so so the in the end uh you know we
have to decide when we're going to
respond to a person with considered
systems do we know enough to comment
um you know are we going to say
something affirming ambiguous or
negative
as I said negatives a really dangerous
thing to do it's very easy to want to do
it in fact all of our our responses at
the beginning were you know we're
thinking we're very easily kind of you
know giving people a
when you say something sexist why not
let a person know a sexist don't say it
well actually I as you saw we turned it
around and we try to say be inclusive
right
um it's timely and short and simple so
when I made uh I taught a class I taught
the AI class here once a long time ago
and and I had a bunch of people make
these help systems and it was great we
had 60 of them and the biggest
um
value
that I learned from that was it didn't
matter how much AI was in it it mattered
if it could respond fast enough for a
person to use the information while they
were thinking about it if they had to
wait for it the system worked worse and
so timely is important short is
important uh and simple is important
those three things lessons I keep
learning over and over again uh I try to
think about things not being distracting
uh either in visual or auditory ways
um and you know I think that a lot of uh
these systems we build try to put words
in people's mouths
you know when it completes things for me
it's nice saves me time but it's also
not very polite for me to put words in
your mouth and I don't know whether it's
going to come back and bite us but it's
something that I'm thinking about and
really the thing that I like to talk
about is assistive versus advisory
agents so an advisory agent is one that
that teaches you
um and and gives you a suggestion an
assistive agent does it for you
self-driving car versus a car coach that
teaches you to drive better
um and
um
so you know
um
yeah so if you lose subtlety uh you know
you can stop people's thinking if you
push them too hard in any direction I
can be just you know pushing people too
hard or or or
telling them something they should say
can be
disturbing and it makes them feel like
they're losing agency we all spend a lot
of Our Lives hoping that we have enough
well personal power to to be respected
by ourselves and others
um and then there's this whole idea of
side town so that is realizing that I am
actually succeeding at communicating
that those those are some of the
reflective principles that I've come up
with and anyway
um it's 5 30 and I just wanted to end
exactly on time and say that
um uh that we've been building this uh
social network uh learning
um Learning Network to support women and
it probably will care about other people
but besides women at some point but uh
also this idea of communication
reflection I think is a broader topic
than just uh what we're doing in the app
and um anybody that's interested uh we
I'd be delighted to talk to you about
about ways that this stuff can go
forward and be useful
um as a technology uh so thank you very
much
um and I leave you with the four traits
of of Alfie are optimism ambition
bravery and kindness and uh that was
another thing we thought of is that
instead of just having
um a simple uh yes no we wanted to give
people a direction a vector about where
what what it what what would it mean to
to to give people feedback that was that
was um not not just bad or good but took
you in a different direction so thank
you very much for attending and I opened
any questions
yes we do and if you hope question and
you're on the net you just unmute
yourself and ask the question
identify who we want
ah
yes
I'm just going to wait till after two
questions
any other questions out there
I think nothing yet so so I have two
one's a fairly short yes or no and the
other one is slightly more detailed
because so no no seriously I mean I
looked right into Seattle
talking about this
um when you when you mention women here
are you including trans women
I'm included but we're all about
inclusiveness okay now I mean there's
women who do not include trans women as
women so and there's and yeah I I I just
want to I've had lots of people work
with me that that are all every every
shade of the of the gender yeah
it's not a line it's it's a spectrum
well
my second one in terms of most of the
examples I think you showed uh
have a particular component of what we
would call interest that a lot of people
would have
and when I started talking to other
people a couple decades back about when
Sergeant bomb is pushing expert systems
yes he was uh fifth generation okay yes
no no yeah too but I mean actually at
the last open computer forum and stood
up and he apologized
that's very interesting but there's
probably a question here yeah
yeah you know some some degree of
empathy yes for for the system of both
machine and people for somebody who
might be helped and I thought that the
exam a good example that might need to
be painted would be something like
what we would call social worker so we
had the EDD up in Sacramento and they
have to make the decision how do they
know how does a person
know whether or not somebody is actually
trying to gain the welfare system or not
that you you hear this story and you
know I get emails all the time I you
know we're in fact you know I get the
word sorry as an example no medical
problem
and um you know you're a patient or
you're really part of EDD no not well
I'm just talking about the emails you're
getting right
right EDD has this person or this
problem that they have but they only
have so much Personnel yet they have
this flood of people especially during
the pandemic and they have to make
and you know that's at the state level
what does EDD stand for Employment
Development you know and of course at
the national level at the beginning of
the pandemic you know there was this
dispersal of money and it's a fair
number of people not not the majority
certainly uh you know did multi-million
dollar scams on on the Federal
disimbursement
of funds but at the same time at the at
the lower level
there were smaller people in in build
real need and determining what what the
availability
the amount of funds to disperse how can
you I mean do you have some things to
think yeah there's all sorts of
questions there so number one they're
sensing you have to understand uh what
what you know whether a person's being
truthful or not and whether they are
making a good argument or not and
whether they are they actually their
argument actually represents
um a need that is real so those are
three different things that we have to
we have to measure
um and uh we don't have the Personnel
because we think we can do it a better
simpler way that's fine so I don't think
that that's actually I don't I don't
actually it doesn't bother me that it
takes a lot of people to figure out if
people have needs I think it's worth
worth people have needs but but in fact
yes there are things we can do to
automate things like that I think that
the part you know so there's there's the
parts about measuring it and sensing it
and everything like that but the part
that I'm really caring about mostly is
by in my career is about the part that
people aren't doing which is how do you
how do you even communicate with a
computer how do you communicate with
another person using a computer to
support you in every social situation we
are in now there is also a phone often
there's a phone that's listening for a
question even uh do you know do you want
to find out when the baseball game
starts I mean you know then you just you
know it just and then all of a sudden
it'll pop up in the middle of your
conversation and say you know you know
when it's going to start
um the question is whether that's
appropriate or not and I think that we
have spent way way way too little we've
spent a lot of time thinking oh can we
do a better job of sensing and detecting
and being and finding people that are
cheating and this and that and that yeah
that's that's the field that has you
know you know 10 million people working
on it the the one about trying to make
people feel more comfortable work
together better uh that's not very big
at all and so that's kind of what I'm
standing up here saying I want computers
to be
um eugenic I want them to I mean to work
better with people uh uh and and and
still I will say you know with regard to
your question which
I see why you deserve an answer anyway
um yeah I mean people you know the
computers uh modeling of these of these
conversations getting better and better
and yet you see Facebook who who has to
do this for a living or die
um figure out whether people truth or
not they they have you know an army of
people and an army of bots and I think
that this collaboration between
computers and machines a people is the
most is is the most fun thing we have we
always have been playing with machines
and collaborating with with each other
using you know uh whether it's a saw
that has two handles or whatever
um we're collaborating with another
person and and that will continue and I
want to celebrate that I want to
celebrate the integration of using
computers for what they're good for and
have them communicate with people in a
way that makes people
um succeed better and feel better about
themselves and each other
augmentation
yeah
no I'll call it learning
okay so the augmentation you know is is
Marvin Minsky one of my dearest dearest
friends until he passed
um
um
um
you know was hoping for you know
augmentation replacement I'm just hoping
to have a good life
and it's getting hard because we got
super computers on our phone in our in
our pockets that are distracting us
enough that we are falling off the Taj
Mahal when the when the phone knows
exactly where we are there's no reason
that phone couldn't have stopped us from
falling off a dodgeball
dinner any questions
anybody online
foreign
basically a you know best selling author
Julian got three started this company
and she wrote a book called Alpha girls
and it was about women that did really
well and she when she goes around giving
talks about it she started recognizing
that there was an awful lot of people
that didn't they were getting ahead
because they had glass ceilings of
various sorts and so she thought you
know wouldn't it be cool to make an app
that would support women advancing and
what she did because it's her wheelhouse
is she got some of the best writers in
the world to write articles
make video tape videos about like you
know what's it mean to Pivot that's
changing kind of job you're in what
inspirational women you know that have
done things gone to space gone down to
the bottom of the sea whatever and she
has articles about them articles by them
um videos about them there's talks that
happen several times a week that are
that are supposed to be inspiring
there's a game you can play that that
kind of makes you think about a person
that's inspiring there's there's uh
social network you can create between
people
to talk about um let's talk about
whatever you want to to you know and
relative to advancing you're feeling
better about about your your chances and
working towards it there's even things
to help you think about how to get to
get better jobs so there's an awful lot
it's it's you know thousands of of
pieces of of of content in it and
there's you know little little lessons
um we might call them uh you know hacks
um so it's it's quite it's quite a
robust platform and I you know I welcome
everybody to try it
um I was just talking about one little
corner of it that's got a lot of
attention this is this way of of
watching a person communicate and
improving their communication and I'm
talking about it because you know it's
it's it's a very direct
um
experiential thing that is that works
with whatever content you're you're
working with so that's different from
the typical stuff which we we have a lot
of in in Alfie that is stuff that's you
know appropriate for for the person that
wants to learn about how how women can
succeed and that's
stuff is is and especially interesting
to me is
that I think that there's very little
um well-written stuff about ageism and
that's that's something we focused on
that I think is is is interesting to to
the world but it's also uh been been
under under people don't know what to do
with it
um and so we're exploring that as well
as uh other things about about
um about about about these these issues
so no thank you for that question uh uh
and yes please
you suddenly worked on this experience
expertise recognition system
that takes your experiences in terms you
how expertise yeah
and you know I give the app a bunch of
my experiences is it going to like give
me a plan give me an idea on how to fix
it sure I mean it could give a per chart
and it could give you again you know to
show you how to do this and then that
and the other thing no what it does is
it uses what it what it watches you do
by watching you it learns your expertise
and experience yes you can fill out a
profile but mostly our idea is that we
watch what you're interested in how you
interact with it what comments you make
and then we suggest other content and
there's a for me page which is a list of
all the things we hope we've thought
through well enough and reasoned well
enough to know would be useful to you
and so that that's that's the idea
yes our activity while using this app
okay so it's not it's not just
collecting it's not just swiping up
everything about you in the world you
know it's not scraping scraping your
Facebook I mean maybe that'd be
interesting but it'd probably be
intrusive so what we're doing is we're
watching how you how do you interact
with our app
you know yeah
is there any more okay
any nobody's raised their hand out there
they're already busy eating dinner
or something but you know it's always
amazing what you get yourself into who
you or me
but this is this is
this interesting AI talk I've heard in a
long time oh thank you so much the
reason for it is that it's
simple and practical and you know have a
fairly high impact
well thank you I think that it's
practical and I actually believe there's
some theoretical uh underpinnings that
you know will seem easy to us afterwards
but have been coming 50 or 60 or 80
years and and that that's the
interesting thing is that this modeling
the the people's response is is a worthy
task in my view yeah and but I think
I think that it points out something
which
I've become to believe that I'm not
really willing to tell anybody I do and
that is
I'm not certain that all of our concern
about privacy and information is in the
long run a practical Choice yeah yeah it
seems to me that if we're going to to
collaborate and cuddle up with these
machines and it's going to help us they
have to be able to know a lot of stuff
about us
and if we try to keep ourselves private
and secret
um and you don't share it across your
little Community
uh you don't get the benefit yeah so I
think it's really an interesting topic
of what it where is privacy come and go
in society and you think about you know
maybe maybe you could imagine Adam and
Eve sitting around a firearm and then
they want to get some privacy so they go
behind a rock right and they get
together and and and so then they you
know say hey it wouldn't be fun if we
could do that anytime from any direction
and they build a little Hut right and so
it's all this sudden they're in the
fireplace with everybody else very much
and then then people then they get
lonely right and they invite people over
to their Hut pretty soon the the front
door is open and everyone's hanging out
in the Hut and so they have to get a
cottage next to the river or something
but you know uh we we have these things
where we like we love having a lawn and
we love being in a you know in a
community and then we put up fences
between our yards and then we find
ourselves never getting to play with the
kids next door and I remember going uh
you know just delivering somebody that
had been you know you know
uh doing some labor to to a community in
Mountain View which had this huge
apartment complex and everyone was
jammed together and there's a little
swimming pool between everybody and the
kids are just running all over the place
all the doors are open everybody's
playing together and I was thinking you
know my kid was with me he says why can
I can I play here and I said well we
have to ask you know but you probably
and the point being that you know
there's there's a lot lost in privacy uh
at that you you know there's a lot to
learn by being with others well I think
the part of the problem unfortunately is
the Caucasian population of the United
States is that a sexist statement yeah
yeah
this is I mean I I grew up in Southern
California where we had fences and one
of the first things you learned when
you're when you released a boy at the
time is you learn how to climb with cats
and that's something Steve Crocker at
UCLA was noted for very early on on the
orphan
example
clocked over transoms to get the access
but the thing is I think one of the
things that surprised me on my first
business trip
was the number of communities that
really they had they did not have fences
so your next door neighbor was actually
fairly close by and you know you
share certain things in commonly that
was not the case
in Southern California now Southern
California
well anyway I bet we digress yeah
and when I talk to people about privacy
we'll stop I I do kind of describe to
mcneely's privacies
but I'll I'll play Both Sides
the people that really who really
understand privacy actually if you want
to meet people who really know privacy
my suggestions go visit the hoagie
reservation in Arizona they understand
privacy
and the ones that you don't do don't
don't take pictures of the hoping okay
why because they think you're stealing
their soul yeah they they really do and
they have a particular point the problem
that we have in our society is
you want to have a
limited controlled space but then that
thing
to take your message in order for you to
help your economic interest
life and I I face
you know a lot of people just assume
that hey I'm an extension of the white
race but when I go to a Native American
or First Nations reservation
I hear very different conversations than
if I had a Caucasian friend I mean you
know race aside everybody has this
situation I was describing which is this
this tension between whether to share or
whether to keep keep to themselves and
you know in the in because we're social
animals eventually people need to be
around other people
um for lots of reasons and and in fact
you know privacy cannot be complete and
uh you know and and yet um you know
sharing can't be complete uh and I think
that those those those those those
you know those those are real real
issues and you know I mean I remember
when Google was a one-story building and
I used to go visit my friends over there
you know and and we just I just walk in
the door and it was open and and you
know just sit down and hang out and go
to and have food and yeah me too I had
the same day
sure in their Top Ramen phase yeah yeah
and but they can't do that as easily now
I don't know I hope not
I definitely know that they have that
they have to keep this thank you very
similar to the Colossians anyway yes I
am my suggestion though is I think we
should
and one more one more shout out if
anybody online has some
yeah
that's uh call us today thank you very
much this is a great talk oh thank you